welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and loki unveiled the villain
behind the curtain of the marvel
cinematic multiverse
kang the conqueror confirmed in the
recent assembled documentary to return
in various
forms in future marvel titles the
variant of
he who remains the one he's been talking
about the one that he's so afraid of
is kang kang is bent on destruction
and i'm so curious to see what jonathan
does
kang lives in so many iterations as he
who remains says reincarnation
baby and while we have been suspecting
it was kang all along
from the various clues pointed out in
episode breakdowns one line that stuck
with me as evidence kang might have been
hiding behind those curtains like a
crapo long before
loki episode one i've lived a million
lifetimes
i've gone through every every scenario
this is
the only way yes a direct link to doctor
strange in avengers infinity war
who looked ahead at 14 605 future
outcomes and found
only one successful path forward tony
there was no other way strange's one
path was a path that
kang actually paved for him every step
you took to get here i
paved the road
you you just walked down it
we already know that kang is fully aware
of his infinity saga predecessor thanos
in episode two a multiple choice
question for miss minutes used thanos
going back in time to eat apples as an
example and now he who remains munches
on an apple
i believe partly as a way of saying i'm
eating the apples now but tom
hiddleston used an interesting word to
describe kang
the tva had an architect
at the end of time which i think is
confirmation that in addition to
sighted influences like the wizard of oz
and willy wonka he remains parallels the
architect of the matrix who explains to
that anomalistic protagonist that he's
actually in a reboot of the sixth
iteration of his simulation
similarly i think we can now look at all
the events of the mcu
as part of kang's simulation with
various
glitches that i think we can now
interpret as glitches or patches
in kang's matrix in order to alter the
timeline in a way that most
benefits him remember the sacred
timeline is actually a rope-like braid
of several strands
made up of time looping back on itself
in an infinite flat circle
from the big bang to what mt hilariously
called the big crunch
resetting the loop again and again with
one loop where loki's a female variant
one loop where he's an alligator etc and
that only when those variants did
something to ripple effect history into
a nasty kang variant
did he who remains send the tva and to
prune it and according to this show that
led to real
life curiosities like the polybius game
the uss eldridge the sphynx is missing
nose
the stolen 2018 tour de france cup but
within the mcu
there are at least five unexplained
loose ends that
i think could be evidence of a glitch or
kang patching a glitch
within his mcu matrix let's start with
avengers tower that tower appeared in
the void labeled
king q-e-n-g for king enterprises a
company run by mr griffin who is one of
the many incarnations of kang now this
version of the tower has the 2015 era
quinjet landing pad
meaning this would be after age of
ultron when the avengers relocated to
their upstate campus and after that in
homecoming tony stark sold the tower to
some mysterious new buyer and later on
in far from home
set in the year 2024 the unknown
occupant has been remodeling the tower
there's an atrium in it now
it's possible that kang enterprises
could have been that buyer
but since he remains is trying to prune
timelines where rival kang variants are
arising
that could have explained how this
version of the tower ended up in the
void leaving the tower back in the
sacred timeline
the one that we saw after end game and
far from home to be occupied by someone
like reed richards of the fantastic four
making this the new baxter building and
allowing kang to set into motion his
ancestor reed richards so that there
would one day be a nathaniel richards
but look it takes a long time to
re-watch these movies and tv shows find
the clues put together theories that
might not always be accurate
so in the precious few hours i do
finally get a chance to sleep i need a
good mattress to do that on well helix
sleep makes premium mattresses and
bedding that are customized to fit your
needs
and conveniently shipped right to your
door helix made a sleep quiz that
matches your unique body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you
i took that quiz and got matched with
the dusk lux helix mattress because i
wanted a medium burn mattress with
lumbar support that sleeps cool
i've had this helix mattress now for
over a year and i
love it i mean i sometimes lose sleep
thinking about the next day's video but
it's not because of an uncomfortable
mattress this is a mattress i have to be
dragged out of every morning to get my
work day started and if you sleep with a
partner both of you can take the quiz
and find the mattress that meets both of
your needs
the best part about all of this is that
helix delivers your mattress right to
your door
for free it comes rolled up in a box and
it's super easy to set up yourself
it's like a cool magic trick that they
can fit an entire mattress into a box
that size helix has a 100
night sleep trial so you get more than
three months to make sure that you love
it and if you don't they'll pick it up
for you and you'll get a full refund
i love my helix i think you would too
and if you're looking for a new bed
check out helix
you can click the link below or go to
helixsleep.com
new rockstars and get up to 200 off your
helix mattress another loose end that i
brought up in videos before
in avengers end game the quantum tunnel
control panel listed the years 2009
ad and 2988 bc as recent destinations
after the avengers had returned from the
time heist but the avengers never went
to those dates in the movie but these
weren't just random years because 2988
bc was the year
thor's grandfather boar battled with the
dark elves and secured the reality stone
ether 2009 would have been shortly
before tony stark became iron man which
will get revisited and what if
as killmonger saves tony but also we
just learned in black widow around the
time natasha was with hawkeye in
budapest
in her assassination attempt of drakov
and his daughter perhaps both of these
dates were alternate time heist
destinations
that kang pruned from the avengers plan
2988 to force thor and rocket to go to
2013 asgard instead
where thor could get a duplicate mjolnir
that proved crucial in the final battle
against thanos 2009
to miraculously save drakov and his
daughter from what should have been an
expertly rigged detonation
so that they could return as natasha's
ledger
demons ahead of her guilt-driven
self-sacrifice on vormir so that the
avengers could get the soul stone
also obviously instrumental in thanos
downfall but another loose end variant
steve rogers who was allowed to stay
behind with peggy carter in the 1940s
and grow into an old man in an alternate
timeline
but apparently ignored by kang in the
tba why was that well the prospect of
variant captain america
seems to be an especially tricky thing
for kang because think about it you also
have a timeline cat briefly created by
saying
hale hydra and then some alternate
history red guardian seems to genuinely
believe in which he fought a version of
cap and then cap peggy carter coming up
in what if but also peggy carter's
mention of captain britain brian
braddock in the endgame 70s scene
so i am wondering if a captain britain
core is
forming that resists the council of
kangs from pruning
any variant caps throughout the
multiverse there is also the fact that
captain america's shield is apparently
showing up back in ancient babylon in
the eternals now we know
kang has a bit of an obsession with the
seven wonders of the ancient world based
on the void containing both the pyramids
of visa
and the lighthouse of alexandria so if
this guy made changes to those two
things
wouldn't it also make sense for him to
have visited the hanging gardens of
babylon
but a version of the sanctum sanctorum
also appeared in the void suggesting
that there was a timeline in which
kang pruned the sorcerers this is the
lucen that has me the most excited for a
multiverse of madness because if you
think about it
other than kang and his tva only the
ancient ones seem to have any
insight into the sacred timeline in the
mcu doctor strange's future as a
sorcerer was
known years in advance by the ancient
one and even more weirdly by hydra
yet like he who remains the ancient one
could not see
beyond her death which makes it
especially interesting that doctor
strange
could see one out of 14 million 605
futures
despite dusting shortly after that and i
think that was only possible because
kang scripted that path for him could
part of he who remains success in
resolving the multiversal war
have been an alliance with the ancient
one to keep the avengers from rupturing
his sacred timeline beyond repair during
their time heist because she seemed
pretty insistent that they keep that
timeline from rupturing if she was
bragging to steven strange about a vast
multiverse
why would she care about keeping the
timeline so in order so that could
explain
why that particular sanctum got pruned
that could be from a timeline where
someone else was a sorcerer supreme
before the ancient one struck a deal
with he who remains
so that she could ascend to the
sorcerer's supreme in this timeline
and preside over an earth and serve as
kang's liaison
to the avengers that could be why the
one major branch from the time heist
that the avengers never went back to
patch
the escape of loki variant l-1130 which
led to his
link with l1190 something that was so
devastating to he who remains his
timeline and necessitated a deadlier
kang to take his place
look there are plenty of other
unanswered questions in the mcu that we
could blame on kang like could that
homecoming eight years later timeline
up ben kang's fault
did kang recast rody and bruce banner
the same way nexus being one to maxima
for recasted pietro could jimmywoo's
missing witness had been a variant is
endgame gamora a variant that plays a
role in king's scripted future
all possibilities i will explore in
future videos trust me comment down
below with your theories and remind her
to get our loki inspired merch at
newarkstarsmerch.com time is running now
it's about to go back in the vault
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos follow and subscribe to new
rockstars thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you